hey i'm dave rubin welcome to the rubin
report which is vladimir putin's
favorite show okay we've got two of my
favorite guests jen hoffman and dave
holmes i was just informed they did a
pilot together once called gasps psychos
yeah which uh well okay we and never
aired never aired never aired pilot we
will try to find it and bring it to you
next time alright we got a lot of great
stories for you and we're starting off
with this the stoli boycott in Russia
you know we talked about this last week
the Olympic 2014 games are in Sochi
Russia and Russia has been doing a slew
of anti-gay stuff all these new anti-gay
laws they can arrest gay people now
there's been a ton of hate crimes all
absolutely terrible stuff and in
response to this the gay community here
in the United States and all over the
world actually spearheaded by Dan Savage
who is a sex therapist but somehow has
become like the end-all be-all to the
gays are launching a boycott for Stoli
vodka products let's take a look at the
statement so this is dan Savage there is
something we can do right here right now
sabat wrote to show our solidarity with
Russian queers and their allies and to
help draw international attention to the
persecution of gay men lesbians
bisexuals trans people and straight
allies in Putin's increasingly fascist
fascistic is that a word fascistic
Russia dump Russian vodka we can also
show you the image of the the official
boycott logo because you gotta have a
logo if you're doing a boycott it's got
a shared on Facebook if no one knows to
do unless you how to share yeah you have
to you have to share everything now real
quick it should be noted that actually
Stoli is not even based in Russia they
left Russia about 10 years ago they're
based in Luxembourg also they're
involved in a lawsuit with the Russian
government about branding right now they
have sponsored gay pride things in the
past they're sponsoring gay stuff right
now they've already issued plenty of
statements backing the gay community
this seems completely misguided to me
this is like boycotting Snapple because
you don't like America's drone use or
something like I just don't see the
connection between a company and the
government are you guys with me on this
confusing because I'm not exactly sure
if it's Luxembourg or Latvia but
supposedly the holding company that
still owns it is Russian base right and
they still make it in Russia raw
materials are still Russian I think it's
still distilled in Russia so it's
something you know what does that does
that make a difference like dessert does
a vodka company run the Russian
government and make their law these
kinds of things I think affect the wrong
people I don't think Vladimir Putin is
really gonna be too bothered by it I
think I gonna you know the people who
provide the potatoes or whatever goes it
I'm not really living wherever like in a
field to need their income from actually
making the vodka or now my maybe could
be affected by it but not the government
yeah it seems to me like a boycott is
something you do when it's like you
don't like an episode of modern family
or whatever or like you know to me like
this is a serious thing like they're
throwing gay people and trans people in
jails it's not like you know it's not
like oh we don't like you know they
don't have enough social services for
lesbians in Russia no they're like
wholesale putting gay people and their
supporters in jail this needs to get
serious so like you know yeah I think
this thing is kind of weak but if it
makes people take notice then it's a
good thing I think let's put all our
cocktails away for five minutes and
figure out what it is that we're
actually gonna do like let's let's pull
out of this Olympics right so you think
the United States should actually pull
out of the Olympics do you think that
that's like a legit because this is such
a severe human rights issue you either
believe that gay people are people or
you don't and if you believe that there
people then then this is wrong yeah you
can't you can't it doesn't you can't go
halfway yeah yeah it's kind of like the
chick-fil-a thing I mean people
boycotted chick-fil-a when they're
saying you know they obviously are
giving money towards anti-gay marriage
you know things but then in the end
chick-fil-a I still prevailed still
exists or stole a line around the corner
to get in so it's it's great that it you
know it'll make people more aware
there's media awareness we're talking
about it Russia eventually we'll have to
make some sort of statement if they feel
like at least rushing companies maybe
not putin himself right so the media
awareness is great it's great that
people feel like they're doing something
but just the absence of drinking a
certain vodka and ordering a different
vodka instead at a bar like you were
saying just you know put down the drinks
and maybe talk about it isn't really
going to affect any social policy and
there's any
change or anything real do you think you
also actually strengthen the other
side's hand in a weird way because
chick-fil-a is the perfect example their
sales had never been better when this
whole thing was going down with them so
you may end up yeah you're gonna hurt
Stoli which was just the random what
there's plenty of vodka company is in
Russia they picked Stoli to attack but
you may end up helping other Russian
vodkas although some other vodka
companies from outside Russia are now
really doing a lot of promotion and
promoted tweets on Twitter because they
want to jump on the ante Russia I don't
think the thing well first of all the
thing was never just dan Savage started
as queer nation and he sort of gave it a
bigger platform or whatever and it also
has never been just dump Stoli that's a
that's a quick and easy way it was
alright but I've seen for whatever
reason it seems to have jumped on stones
cheap and easy to buy and people
recognize Stoli and because it actually
has you know says from Russia and a lot
of things some of it says bottle it they
all say different things by the way
different bottles of it I was just in
Palm Springs this weekend and every
single restaurant there that I saw don't
do I don't know if they have this in
West Hollywood right now haven't been
out partying in West Hollywood in a
while but in Palm Springs which is
obviously a very gay friendly community
the restaurants do have signs up at
specifically say we are now not serving
Russian vodka you know they have a
little rainbow martini glass and it's
all very cute and Italy I didn't know
about it so at least it did raise my
awareness it raised the awareness of
people that i was there having my brunch
with we're very aware at brunch some are
having brunch you're just pretty good
are you already doing st. pro yeah okay
there's a bunch of straight people
having some gail brunch yeah um brunches
they're gay or like annoying girls I'm
annoying girl so I was having brunch um
but yeah I mean Italy love being set
next to you about our boyfriends in
right no horrible and are still in our
clothes from last night being terrible
terrible people the best brunch is
terrible thing yeah basic boy Tommy
brunch we got right about that yeah yeah
I know but I think in the first place it
did make us talk about that it did raise
a little bit of awareness at the table I
think a lot of other people coming into
the restaurant were wondering wine at
least thinking about it and then it made
you go okay what's really going on in
Russia and look a little deeper than
that so that was a good thing but in the
end and get it didn't affect anything
specifically it's not gonna change
Russia's policy known in Russia feel no
no the gay you know or bisexual people
in Russia or now like I feel
better thanks a lot no jail my family
has less money because they're not
buying my potatoes or whatever but yes
honestly I don't think out of jail
because you're not buying my potato
right right yeah I do think that these
things do kind of help a little bit
divestment in South Africa you know I'm
not gonna play sun city all that stuff
it raised awareness and it worked
eventually right like you know little
Stephen himself did not end apartheid
but it worked right so did our five okay
so do you think that in the short term
that perhaps harming some of these
companies which again we're all agreeing
you're just really harm harming the
potato guys and the people that work in
the factories that really in the bigger
picture that is it worth it you know do
the ends justify the means in a case
like this I I think so I do i do think
so and if it makes Stoli rethink their
practices a little bit because you know
right now you know you said that they're
they're like you know they they invest
in the gay community they advertise in
the gay community right a market to us
but isn't that but that's what all
companies so a little bit deeper right
but I think that's as you're saying too
though now it's making all these other
Russian vodka companies come out and
through their Twitter and through all
there were social media things making
really strong statement saying we do
support the gay community so even in
just that that you're making other
companies go out there and say hey but
we support you even if it's American
companies of any companies now are being
like okay we don't want to be associated
with being anti-gay or any sort of you
know hate-filled statements if it's
helping organizations feel like there's
going to be pressure on them you know to
be more supportive than it is worth it
yeah do you guys think there's any risk
in connecting companies with countries
so closely regardless of the country and
again not diminishing the importance of
this issue with the Gator Russia just a
company to industry people do associate
vodka with Russia maybe maybe miss
Association obviously like rigors is in
France and there's different you know
different alcohol comes from different
places than we assume but that being
said it is when you think Russia you do
stereotypically think vodka so I think
that way you are at least attaching it
to something that's a little bit larger
more of an industry than a specific
company true and of course look at the
same point we get oil from Russia we get
oil from Saudi Arabia where they still
be head gay people but you know you
can't figure out exactly where your oil
is coming from when you go to to the gas
station so it's obviously very complex
and and we're gonna we're gonna keep
talking about it
yeah I needed we're going to finish this
with a nice bottle of Stoli okay all
right let's move on so CNN's Don Lemon
has gotten in a lot of hot water this
week for some comments he made which
originally started when Bill O'Reilly
made some comments in the aftermath of
the Trayvon Martin case and Bill
O'Reilly been talking a lot about
black-on-black crime and he's been
getting a lot of guff from from liberals
saying you know he has no right to talk
about it and well let's let's watch the
clip one of those honest people CNN
anchor Don Lemon who reference my
talking points on his program he's got a
point in fact he's got more than a point
bill raised without much structure young
black men often reject education and
gravitate towards the street culture
drugs hustling gangs nobody forces them
to do that again it is a personal
decision he is right about that too but
in my estimation he doesn't go far
enough miss lemon then went on to list
things that African Americans should do
to combat social problems after his
remarks mr. lemon was predictably
attacked by the race hustlers but his
courage stands in stark contrast to
their ignorance and corruption I should
say by the way Donna Don Lemon is a
friend of mine so in full disclosure
something I don't know something like
that disclosure I'm just gonna drop a
name roll yeah yeah he's a good buddy we
could hang out all that no but I don't
know it might affect my opinion on this
somehow first off can I confirm we're
all white here is that fair to say very
white white white white okay so part of
me was thinking can we even talk about
this so that's where I want to start on
this the racial stuff I think partly
what's going on here is that the black
community doesn't want bill o'reilly
talking about their dirty laundry I
don't think they're necessarily
disagreeing with the heart of it and
that's what Don's talking about but they
just don't want someone like Bill
O'Reilly talking about it so is that in
itself
do you then he's Gargamel you know he is
like no reference he doesn't you know
he's not really with the time since the
sara lee's not even socializing probably
right now he does his job and he you
know has a dinner and goes home yeah the
staff yeah squeeze his staff fire
somebody goes home so to your point I
always first went talking about these
things say as somebody who is not black
I can't necessarily speak on their
experience with this but of course you
can solve an opinion right of course the
thing is I what I don't understand about
what Bill O'Reilly said is why it's it's
just your main two black teens you know
black kids in general I think I black
kids in jail kids in general yeah
gravitate towards that kind of thing
especially you know economically
disadvantaged kids so it's not strictly
a black problem right you know i think
you know if you if you go the jesse
pinkman route you're gonna have a tough
time getting jobs that is a white
problem and a black problem if you if
you dress and look and you know if you
if you act any any way that is sort of
outside of corporate america you're at a
disadvantage that's not it's not hateful
thing it becomes a hateful thing when
you're Bill O'Reilly and you say that
it's only black kids who do that right
where there's just no weapons but the
people that are defending O'Reilly are
saying he's bringing up a legitimate
argument that yes the tray vibe Bill
O'Reilly knocked him I don't think at
least he doesn't seem to be diminishing
what happened with Trayvon at all or
even defending Zimmerman it seems to me
that he's trying to address a separate
issue which is the the black on black
crime but it's just simply they don't
hear from somebody that's a problem and
also the fact that he attached it to the
Trayvon Martin thing if you still want
to attach the fact that this kid should
be dead in any way because he was
wearing a hoodie or because he looked
maybe a little like like he wasn't on
his way to his corporate job with his
briefcase you know and how to succeed in
business without really trying musical
style yeah you know then that's a
serious problems and O'Reilly is kind of
still saying oh you brought it upon
yourself it's like that is I think why
people have a little bit of outrage with
him because with him and what he says
it's never really just about what he's
talking right okay so then that's where
we should bring it out well then that's
where we should bring in Don Lemon
because Don Lemon is black and he is
acknowledging that he's trying to
address that you know pull up your pants
and there's in terms of Trayvon Martin
are you doing it in terms of jobs in the
workplace cuz if he's saying look you
know as a black man on television using
some sort of position of influence he's
saying yo look
black people in our city yeah hey yeah
hey there black folk I don't know how
he's addressing them besides the fact
that he's saying to them he agrees in
his personal position he probably did
not get to be an anchor in such a
high-profile person rightly and without
you know having to and he brings up you
know being eloquent speaking a certain
way being educated he brings up other
things certainly besides just the way
you dress and he does make a point he
makes a point as you were saying not
just for the black community but for any
teenagers that you know are just not
just a purpley they're probably not
gonna get the job over somebody else who
comes in looking a little bit more work
appropriate right I think him as a
high-profile black man was saying
speaking to his community specifically
saying that he agrees and he wouldn't be
where he is and probably his peers
wouldn't be where they were unless they
took some sort of responsibility for
their behavior and the way they present
them right so that that's the part that
I find sort of bizarre about this whole
thing is that the way though it seems
white people's reaction to Don Lemon Don
Lemon no community should have the same
opinion about every anything you know
you me there shouldn't be one uniform
opinion on anything so the way though
even Don's guest in the original clip on
this immediately attacked him and said
oh you're buddies with O'Reilly now and
he would love what you're saying but
shouldn't the black community like any
community be able to express have a
variety of opinions absolutely of course
yeah yeah it was pretty simple yeah yeah
I mean there's it's um but can't we do
two things at once well it's it's a much
deeper problem and I think you know it's
it's so it's really hard to agree with
Bill O'Reilly you feel terrible yeah and
it's like you know basically on the
surface what he's saying it's not wrong
but it's such a deep social problem yeah
like just being like oh you know we're
different things and don't gravitate
toward gangs and drugs is so let them
eat cake it's not even funny right you
don't to be access to those things isn't
as easy or not necessarily readily at
you know it's not really accessible the
role models that are telling them do
that having parents in the home whether
you have a father and a mother whether
you have or two mommies into daddy's but
just having more people there no I mean
I mean in any way having more people to
turn to having mentors in your community
getting you know adequate education
that's funded adequately by the state
having access to clothing because your
parents are actually there and care
about what you we're not just going to
you know whatever okay so but it's just
yeah we there needs to be a much deeper
discussion but you're not gonna have
that
gushin on Fox News or on / ah because
there isn't the time and like they I
mean they should they have they have 24
hours a day they're just afraid you'll
turn the channel to something else and
so right it mean it's you know it they
need there needs to be a much deeper
discussion right so worried and even us
here we're doing this here in six or
eight minutes real quick but is part of
the problem that we don't seem to be
able to discuss two things at once in
America so everything is one side
screaming one thing the other side
scream the other instead of their in a
way I think they're both making
legitimate points there are there are
obviously racial problems in this
country without question and that nobody
is arguing that but then can Don also
make his point in any sort of dialogue
and I think what you're basically saying
is not on TV yeah just as we can't get
as deep in a to Dave's absolutely right
because it does go back to everything
else that you have to go down to and
it's also individuals every individual
is a different situation and also goes
down to teenagers I don't think when i
was a teenager that i was in any way
dressing speaking or acting
inappropriately just to enter the
corporate world like they would have
been like that we're not hiring you're
insane you have pink hair and you're you
know just all the different I'd pink
hair last year and I'm you know
supposedly grown woman so I think
there's lots of different factors that
go into it that if we can't discuss it
right here and we're not on that cable
news pressure to have the ratings
immediately whatever then how could they
ever possibly get to the root of the
problem right and honestly I would like
to know more about Don lemons experience
I was like you know how he got where he
got but again that is that is such a
long story that TV is just not gonna
give him the time for it I don't know if
he has like a blog or if he's going to
write a book or whatever but I would
like to read that blog or book yeah
alright well I hope in our six or eight
minutes that we just did there we gave
you a little something to think about
something we thought we definitely
solves it all the racial problems and
the cable those problems all in one
segment pretty pretty amazing all right
let's move on actually we should have
probably talked a little bit about guns
in that last segment because that does
have something to do with the whole
issue and right now Arkansas is
definitely the NRS favorite state
because Clarksville high school in
Arkansas is going to be arming 20
teachers administrators and staff yeah
they're giving them 1,100 bucks each to
purge
just a hand gun in a holster they're
going to get training and we will have
armed teachers in the school this is
completely bonkers but let's talk about
it anyway um what a great learning
environment what what it like what a
terrific way to prime your brain for new
information yeah the constant fear of a
gun violence now I you know I you could
argue that those kids are already living
under the constant threat of gun
violence but but at least could be wait
how could you argue that what what kind
of silent people do break into school oh
okay yeah but at least you could think
of that as theoretical now these kids
know that there are actual guns in the
schools with their teachers who they
don't necessarily trust yeah I was a
teacher for two years little-known
random fact I was a high school teacher
for two years and it was a teacher at at
at risk school where they're some of the
kids had actually been in that school
because of gun violence specifically so
there was a little bit of a heightened
threat because some of these kids have
like the ankle bracelet some of these
kids a lot of them came from you know
homes with violence in them the first
thing I can say is as a teacher you are
so overworked and underpaid and stressed
out and have such long hours and there's
so much chaos going on in a high school
classroom even if you run your classroom
very well and I feel like because I was
yeah I was pretty young when I was
teaching the kids kind of had a little
bit of trust with me that they don't
necessarily have as the teachers get
older even in my room and if it was very
functional there was always just you
know 45 kids to manage and a lesson plan
to get out and who hasn't eaten today
and so many different things that a
teacher's responsible for that to add it
after managing and caring of a firearm
on top of that is just completely
inappropriate to put on top of a
teacher's job or they already have so
many jobs to do number one right number
two this program costs about fifty
thousand dollars per teacher in the end
to you know to arm them to train them
all this stuff it's estimated it's
costing the state of Arkansas but fifty
thousand dollars per teacher yeah why
couldn't you if they're gonna arm all
these teachers take fifty thousand
dollars for one or two or three
potential security guards if you do want
to introduce guns to school that's a
whole other argument should even
security guards have them why not have a
trained professional who knows what to
do with guns they're you know they're in
case anything can happen rather than a
teacher really I
care if you give them a couple hundred
hours of training that's not their
primary duty what they're focused on
third thing is teachers or people and
there's human error so teachers do have
personal relationships with kids there's
been at least I'm telling you here
teacher at least one student has
threatened you and said I'm gonna kill
your ass that it just adds the human
element of it what's the teachers excuse
then Oh a kid came to school today and
said that he was gonna kill me because I
gave him bad grade I had to shoot him
he's I had to shoot him so the human
error there and the moon and then a
lawsuits that will happen when a teacher
finally doesn't use the farm writer when
it kid gets a hold of one I mean even if
the teachers whole string and how do you
know kids not gonna grab it so let's
listen to anything let's take it to that
place because we can talk about it in
theory but the logistical nightmare
alone so should the teacher have the gun
on the multum should it be in a locked
drawer and then if it is well it's
probably too late mcgary shooting
precisely so and I feel like the
teachers because this isn't a mandatory
thing it's voluntary and the the the
teachers that are going to opt-in are
the ones who have these nut job
fantasies where like you know a gunman
is coming into the school but there they
got ice cold water running through their
veins and they're just like they're
gonna be you know i mean like down i'm
gonna take this guy out which by the way
no you're not like no human being ever
is so it's it's gonna be these like gun
happy people with like vigilante you
know hero fantasies yeah and who are
were more likely to shoot and so that
that worries me did it the the thing
that really bothers me though is that
like unfortunately this is the logical
end of our gun culture you know what i
mean like barring some sort of massive
shift in our cultural consciousness this
is just the way it's going to get well
that's the gun lobby has one that's the
sick part remember when wayne lapierre
the president of the NRA we remember
when he said a gun in every school and
only a good guy with a gun can stop a
bad guy with a gun and we were all that
was right after Newtown and everyone was
like oh this guy's bonkers well now we
are only what six eight months of after
that or at most 10 month and already
it's it's begun so and we couldn't pass
meaningful gun legislation a couple
months ago so it's like does this all
just slip early a slippy slides nope
look we're slope into arm every teacher
and have every teacher start to say it's
my right to feel safe at my job to carry
a
at school and it's completely
inappropriate for any teacher I don't
care what you're saying unless you're
off duty thing has to learn to train and
become a security guard if you're a
teacher you have no business having a
gun on you while you're trying to
educate a classroom that's a complete
separate job the security and safety of
the classroom while you are in charge of
the general safety and making sure
nothing bananas is going on in your room
to add that on top of it it just means
that either you do have a vigilante
problem or you feel so unsafe in your
classroom that maybe you want to
reevaluate your position as a teacher
anyway yeah is there any way to reverse
any of this though if we're going down
that route yeah what's been shot that's
how it gets reversed a teacher had goes
through it they could get shot that
kills get reversed all the time it is
just smacks room I don't know I I don't
think I then that person will get
written off as a crazy yeah and then
I'll be like well then we need to have
background checks for the teachers are
doing and marijuana once when they know
it's unconstitutional have background
checks for the teachers we're now
unfortunate it's a bummer I the V I want
to know who's gonna be the first to like
shoot into the air to quiet down the
classroom right because that I feel like
will happen on the third day school
right back that's what it seemed cool
exactly that that has to happen here
unfortunately you can arm these people
something has to happen they're not
doing it so nothing will happen
something will happen someone's gonna
shoot they're gonna shoot through the
roof and then just keep kill the kid
upstairs like it just it does not end
well it's I hated the fact that when the
Newtown parents were were kind of front
and center when they're we were trying
to pass some kind of sensible gun
legislation pro-gun people were saying
well you're just that was an emotional
appeal that was that was a there was a
weak emotional appeal you know to
people's you know its sympathy or
whatever yet somehow this ridiculous BS
about like a good guy with a gun being
the only person who can stop a bad guy
with a gun which by the way is jet
appeals to your lizard brain just as
much but not more somehow it has made it
possible to have like now now armed
teachers at school arkansas why did you
write it also is the same emotional
knee-jerk reaction because the same it
way that they're saying that they were
using them into the families in
Connecticut tomb appealed you like oh we
can't have guns it is the exact same
knee-jerk reaction to the other side of
like Oh kids got shot arm everyone likes
jazz well that's something everyone
doesn't mind the emotional appeal they
just want it to be their emotions that
you share with them all right well let's
let's move on from guns to weed I think
we're gonna have a slightly more fun
with this topic okay this is this is
great you know here in California we
have medicinal marijuana and weed is now
legal for recreational use in Colorado
and in Washington and the California
Democratic Party has passed a resolution
this past weekend asking for now backing
legalizing weed in this state altogether
recreational medicinal the whole thing
the problem here is that the feds are
completely against this and our
president barack obama who has sort of
always been this kind of cool you know
there's stories in smoking some weed and
he jokes about it at the washington
correspondents dinner he's still raiding
legal weed dispensaries here in
california now so i want to start with
talking about obama here is is this just
really bizarre about him personally
where he's made it clear he has smoked
weed and does not have a problem with
smoking weed and yet for some reason
still is ordering the feds to raid
medicinal marijuana dispensaries here in
california I've never understood it I've
just never understood never understood
it under any president and especially
now when it when states are one by one
making it legal I don't know if you
spend one dollar and 20 minutes on on
this that is an enormous waste of
resources so does it make it seem like
this doesn't have to do with him and it
has to do with the bigger sort of
government and the way that their loot
spaceforce federal right yeah exactly
that kind that somehow even though
personally he made by I don't want to
give him a pass on this one though this
seems like something that's so obviously
he's personally for and yet doesn't do
what needs to be done do you think it's
possible that he's so worried about his
legacy now but he doesn't want to be
known as like you know the president who
was so left because everyone babes in
that they call Mike a socialist nazi
which doesn't make sense it's like
you're using to like antonyms
I don't know either way I think that
sometimes there could be a little bit of
fear with him that he doesn't wanna be
known as the president that was like
sure have we not you know be so hot that
we loving gay love it that's one same
because he's come out you know finally
he's come out in support of you know gay
measures and he's come out in support of
a lot of other things that people
associate with being liberal and he's
raised the dead a lot and I just don't
know if he wants to be that guy who
everyone goes was the most liberal
president in history because he wants to
see maybe a little bit more moderate I
think that's possible except the part
that doesn't quite jibe with me on that
is he could just say nothing about this
and just not order the feds this comes
from the feds so it's his administration
he could just do nothing and let
California do whatever they're doing
super to the right and go these are
states right things which would appease
the right the impies conservative and if
they say anything about it he'd have to
go well look at what you say you say you
want to be able to control abortion in
your own state you want to be going to
control all these things in your own
state your state's rights people if your
conservative states rights and just drop
the microphone and run Eve it alone
right but it's like with abortion and
with gay rights they only believe in
states rights when the government is not
doing what they want them to do so do
what do you think in terms of just the
battle between the state and the Fed
here should a state have more power to
control what their state's laws yeah
absolutely but only the things that I
agree precisely yes at least your
intellectual yards you do get a little
bit upset when you hear that a certain
state least you for me personally like
oh they're banning abortion or there's
something I'm like however my do that
the federal government needs to step in
and say they can't do that because we
added it it I have the right and like
what we don't relieve a constitutional
right to abortion so maybe that is a
states rights thing and i will get
heated about that so I understand but
that being said I don't know if
marijuana itself is making people in
other states so angry that they're going
on California make sure they don't get
their weed I don't know if that's as
much as an emotional right yeah that's
the part that seems bizarre to me
because I can understand the abortion
issue is a life-or-death issue
regardless of what side you're on but
the weed thing this is basically
something that people do in the privacy
of their own home that does not cause
any violence or car accidents there's no
study you know Aaliyah get giddy eat
food all the hack jokes we can do about
that protesting many marijuana things
the way they protest like abortion
clinics and things like that it's not as
heat it sounds personal even though it's
highly
personal choice it's not his personal an
issue doesn't inflamed people so I don't
understand maybe the DEA needs to keep
going for some reason or they need a
hobby I don't to me doesn't make sense
either why this federal let this be a
money thing could this purely be a money
thing that somehow by keeping weed
illegal the government in a weird way is
making money you know if we really get
it to some conspiracy level because of
smoking weed maybe it has something to
do with the way you keep the war on
drugs going because they're getting back
and money somehow in the Fed something
like that we are a definite that was
another there has to be there absolutely
is some sort of financial incentive to
keep this going on there has to be some
sort of deal with whoever's running the
drugs first government that there's
something going on who knows what it is
but it's gone past what people care
about and the whole public pretty much
is like we don't care who smokes we
leave people alone there's got to be
financial things going on it yeah you
can buy the forest grow your own right
just keep it a backyard operation right
keep it in your own which actually in
California now if you are licensed to do
it you can grow your own and and just
hope I guess that the feds won't bust in
on that for some what governor because
they can always figure out some reason
to do something right alright we're all
pro weed around here okay all right
let's move on to Mark Zuckerberg and
Facebook are you guys still on Facebook
it seems like it's lost a little bit a
little bit of its Jawad to be um he made
Mark Zuckerberg the creator or the guy
who stole Facebook whatever that whole
movie was about he made three point
eight billion dollars last week billion
that's billion with the be 3.8 billion
dollars in one day because I'm not even
gonna get into specifics the IPO on the
stocks and blah blah blah 3.8 billion
dollars one man who created some
computer thing that I've never clicked
an add on and i don't understand any of
this is this complete insanity like
we're talking about a number that is so
out of the realm of understanding is
this just completely nuts well it isn't
it isn't i mean it's it has become a
part it has become fully the way that we
communicate with each other right now
whether you're on that thing or not he
he owns he owns the technology that
allows us all to communicate with one
now I don't remember the last time I
spoke on the phone you know and and even
though Facebook has lost a lot of its
luster and just it's it's become nothing
but my relatives posting things from the
daily currant and thinking they're real
I mean what the daily car daily current
is is at like it's like an onion but
like they were like let's like let's be
like the onion but not ever be funny
really and I not do stories that are
sort of within the realm of plausibility
yeah and and and they do that and it is
like michelle bachman filed for divorce
or whatever that's semi plausible it's
not real funny right yet it's all over
my freaking wall yeah it's like like
OMFG can't believe this is happening
well it is getting though yeah yeah that
and you know farmville invites or
whatever but i mean it truly like it is
he is it it is the vehicle through which
all communication takes place now and so
much of your information your
preferences what you like you've allowed
other applications to access it that
therefore know what you like i think
that's really that people go what is it
worth everyone goes I don't click on
these stupid ads it's like the ads are
like a false flag first of all the ads
just got some stupid suckers that heard
you go to get on the facebook that art
way to corporate and old and out of
touch to understand that there's no
reason to buy a Facebook ad really ever
right maybe to bolster things to your
page because you want to get information
out and get more people to like your
page that I understand but just an ad
you know just oh come here and by
jcpenney jeans like you're not going to
win that way but they have so many
people have every demographic from you
know fifteen-year-old on up through you
know my 69 year old mother's on facebook
and she will write my favorite food is
this and I like this and she will click
on things that they know what she's
gonna click on and they know what story
she likes so it's potentially
interesting that the the source of
information you know people hire
marketing firms to you know they'll give
them millions of dollars to a marking
for him to try to figure out what do
people like into trend forecast he is
now built one of the biggest trend
forecasters and predicted particularly
things that will show you what people
like and what they're engaging it yeah
that's the word writing okay well
there's the three client list more than
anything yeah so the 3.8 still seems
crazy to me that just seems like a
number that is
astronomical and out of the realm of
understanding even that that seems
bonkers but I think what you're hitting
on here and that I think is the scary
part is here he's really buying us what
he really owns now is a piece of all of
us and we just keep giving more pieces
of our shells what what is it about us
that we all have this feel that we've
talked about this a lot on the show
about why we keep giving all this
information but what is it about humans
that we just keep giving away everything
and now the government's watching our
metadata and that whole thing and it's
like are we just gonna keep giving
everything away until we're just part of
the matrix you know honestly my parents
raised me never to give people in your
information like always you know
somebody like calls up asking a question
or whatever hang up yeah yeah yeah but
now it's just like sure if you know if
you'll let me like write a blog post or
whatever I'll tell you everything about
myself foursquare you know you couldn't
even tell somebody where you were going
where you were where our house is any
information back when I remember that T
you never talk to strangers don't say
anything in your right now you're
actually facebooking where you are
you're for squaring checking and you're
saying all your preferences you're
actually listing your relatives how they
have the relative finder on facebook
stores is your aunt is this person your
uncle is this person don't worry way out
of it though we're all aware of it and
yet we're willfully doing I'm literally
talking about the three of us everyone's
doing it you want if you're gonna
everyone's doing if and how are you an
individual danger it seems more
palatable yeah so basically we shouldn't
I mean really it is scary and it's
because it's a free service and now we
feel we can't live without it this funny
people thought I'd be like why I can't
delete my facebook how would I
communicate with people by don't have
facebook every day yeah delete it so all
I want to do like every area i'd wake up
saying today's the day and I just never
one day Dave one day all right well
we're gonna post this on Facebook and
don't forget to click like please we can
eat those like sorry strangely by the
way taken down by Facebook or something
weird will happen where the link won't
work or some disks before [ __ ] about
Facebook yeah no no we love your
Facebook and yeah keep up the good work
okay alright one more story for you so
Nate Silver you guys may remember Nate
from the election he is the Guru of
predicting elections he runs the
fivethirtyeight blog he just went over
to ESPN so he's already dominated the
political sphere he's moving over to the
sports world uh in two thousand eight he
correctly predicted the winner of 49 of
the 50 states in the presidential
election the only state he missed was
Indiana
was one point for Obama everybody loves
this guy and he did an interview with
Deadspin talking about the political
climate and television and pundits and
all that let's take a look obviously
there is some sports pundits who were
total hacks but I'd argue that most
political pundits are completely useless
the outliers of the few who are actually
worth reading plus the political pundits
take themselves very seriously read the
new mark leibovich book whereas I think
someone like jay mariotti realized that
he's just trolling people okay so jay
mariotti is a sports writer obviously
mark Leibovich just wrote this book
about how Washington is such an inside
nepotistic psychotic bastion of lunacy
okay so now I like to believe that I'm
someone that's talking politics
sometimes out there in the public sphere
and you guys are joining me for the ride
but I do think he has a great point on
this you know again CNN's bring it back
crossfire idiot from the left arguing
with the hack from the right and they
usually work for one administration
there like that and you know what they
think MSNBC is now hired almost everyone
that has ever worked for Obama Fox hires
karl rove and sarah palin on the other
side is he right though like are there
but are there a couple people that are
genuinely i'm trying to do that here
yeah i don't think the only one but it's
because you have your own venue you know
and and like a person like Andrew
Sullivan has his own venue and he's not
bought and paid for by whatever think
tank or heritage foundation or whatever
to constantly be spouting the talking
points on this channel in that channel
or whatever just because we have these
24-hour news channels does not mean that
we have 24 hours worth of things to talk
about yeah so they fill them with people
who are just paid employees of whatever
side who go out and give a very shallow
argument and then it are rebutted in a
very shallow way and it's a and yet
taken very seriously and their
predictions are taken very seriously I
love a person like Nate Silver who
simply does the statistical analysis
right he's doing hardcore numbers and
it's proven general if he's a stud okay
this thing is numbers that he could just
say by looking at the numbers and the
sheer volume of people now talking about
politics is by the way ten years ago our
news didn't talk about politics so much
or MSNBC
it's all political pundits politics
politics politics he could just look at
and say by sheer numbers you're gonna
have you know ninety percent of people
are going to be or whatever his number
is are gonna be you know spouting off
you know just basically hot air or
whatever their stuff is for their side
without any heavy analysis but there's
got to be something a little more
personal because he's also going after
the people at Politico he's going after
a lot of different kind of news ish
organizations that are online and saying
that they're just also hacks he's a
major thing with political yeah I don't
know it's like this he hates that means
like you know talking about they really
have nothing to say and he'll contribute
to anything I think he's actually says
him about Huffington Post at some point
so he's gone after different
organizations anyway saying that they're
really not contributing anything of
value to you know the political world
but you know I think we are in that
24-hour news cycle now where everyone's
kind of giving opinions and if you look
at it rather than these are not you know
these aren't facts and people giving
teaching you had a think and just
opinions and you can navigate it well
but he definitely does have a point I
don't know what is FIFA specifically
with jay mariotti either he's like yeah
that's like Politico or generati i would
say sports writers know that what
they're doing is essentially frivolous
it creates a lot of money but it's there
it's basically they're talking about a
game right there kind of smiling as
their arguing right rather political
pundits think that what they do is very
very serious yeah and it's just a silly
yeah i mean ultimately it's just a silly
well I'd like to say this was very very
serious today and everything you heard
here is a hundred percent fact these
were no opinions this is factual stuff
that you can now take and teach people
and jen hoffman dave holmes i thank you
guys very much and click Subscribe it's
right down there I like it on Facebook
because if we can't stop that thing
alright thanks guys hey we're doing a
little bonus clip I've got dave holmes
i'm dave rubin two Dame's one clip i
don't know that that's ever been done
before okay so perfect one this is for
just us boys could this possibly be more
perfect for Joseph's noted homosexuals
room craigslist ladles and jelly spoons
the soldiers in Afghanistan are looking
for sex on it it is men looking for
women it is men looking for men it's
probably women looking for women
although I didn't see that specifically
in this story and this this just broke
this morning what happens
miss your lien sorry yeah no that's okay
all right one more time all right so
just start a tab one more temperature
okay hey we've got a little bonus clip
for you i'm dave rubin I've got dave
holmes with me two Dame's one segment
has this ever been done before I don't
think so in the history of anything I
don't think so i think this is a first
yeah and have a perfect one could not
possibly be more perfect craigslist in
Afghanistan yes they have computers &
craigslist in Afghanistan and our
soldiers are using it to hook up its
guys looking for guys its guys looking
for women it might be women looking for
guys I'm not sure about that could be
women looking for women there's a lot of
options on that craigslist there and our
soldiers are looking for sex and it's
breaking should we look at let's look at
some images let's look at some of the
images first please looking for regular
discreet fun on Camp Eggers m4m 25 and
you know they're looking for dl discreet
fun now of course Don't Ask Don't Tell
is gone boom so they're loud and tell
you can advertise and I love it yeah do
you see any problem with you guys can
keep rolling the clips yeah and 20 25
years old just a flanger anyways he's in
his army fatigues now that black box I
assume was added he's he's thick he's
doing class uh yeah I think I think it's
the hottest thing in the world I want to
start pricing tickets to Kabul yeah you
know what I mean you want to enlist
absolutely i think i'm a little bit too
old yeah for that but i but listen I'll
visit yeah tickets have got to be cheap
right I would love to swing by and i
love i love that this kind of fulfills
so many soldier fantasies here I mean
right this is kind of what was playing
in my head when I thought that the Don't
Ask Don't Tell things gonna get lifted
like eventually people are gonna you
know their young men finally all those
websites dedicated to our military
having gay sex could be real wouldn't
that be beautiful thank God I mean you
know honestly I I think it's I think
it's healthy yeah honestly i think it's
it's good that these things are just
kind of out in the open now I mean you
know sort of neither of those people
show their face right and I guess I
would still be semi risky right there's
some shame involved though even though
this is a net people
sex is a natural thing whether you're
having straight sex ur cases but there's
still some level of shame involved in
there yeah there is a little bit there's
a little bit uh and and and I think it's
still like I think still trolling for
sex is illegal is illegal by the
standards in the arm for anyone for any
for heterosexual homosexual whatever I
don't think that kind of thing is still
not acceptable under military law but
it's still incredibly hot and and
anything you know I you know that you're
you're tony Perkins is in your brian
fisher's are gonna get their knickers in
a twist I think anything that makes that
happen is healthy yeah what I think is
fascinating about this is if you guys
looked at the top of the clip there on
the craigslist post it's actually those
are from Iraq because there was so much
of it happening in Iraq if we were to
scroll to the top of that trust me on
this one but you can see it up there see
these are a rehearsal personals because
there was only much hunter so the ones
in Afghanistan are using the Iraq
personals curse because there was so
much dl sex happening in Iraq so that
that kind of just tells you that this
num always goes on oh you think there's
any drawback to it do you think you need
sexually repressed or you know sexually
frustrated people to get out there and
kill the enemy no no no I mean people
get laid they're better yeah yeah I want
them I want them doing it left and right
I want to I want them staying in shape
you know I mean however they can all
right uh yeah I i I'd honestly I do I
think it's a healthy thing get out there
and get you some boys all right that was
the most pro-sex pro army segment we've
ever done I'm proud of us okay
you